people of the internet's retroarching
tour here i'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and here we
are yet again and we are asking the
question
is this the moment that we see hogwarts
legacy yet again that's right sony has
announced a state of play event coming
up this wednesday at 2 p.m pacific time
5 pm eastern time and this is one that
clearly states the focus is to be on
third party releases now i think the
first thing we need to look at is does
hogwarts legacy even qualify let's take
a look at the exact wording of the
playstation announcement i'll pull it up
right here so you guys can see it so
here is the tweet that they sent out
wednesday october 27th again 2 p.m
pacific time but if you actually click
the link there's going to be more
information there that talks a lot more
about this and we can look at that and
see
does hogwarts legacy even qualify so
there are a couple of key lines i want
to draw your attention to we're going to
go ahead and zoom in here so you can see
this a little bit better but the first
one we should talk about is the second
section right here which reads as
follows this time out we'll be focusing
on announcements and updates for
upcoming third-party releases headed to
ps5 and ps4 well there you have it so
far so good hogwarts legacy is a third
party game and it is heading to ps5 and
ps4 now even though hogwarts legacy fits
there we definitely have to talk about
that word upcoming right because what do
they mean by upcoming the most likely
explanation is games releasing before
the end of the year i know that's
probably not what you want to hear but
let's keep reading the show is looking
to be about 20 minutes or so and we'll
share new looks at previously announced
games plus a few reveals from our
partners around the world now i don't
know about you guys but when i hear
updates to previously announced games my
alarm bells are kind of going off and i
know
we find ourselves in the same position
yet again we've been here how many times
now guys on the verge of a big event
saying
yes it's going to be here this is the
moment i'm not going to do that this
time i'm sorry i'm just not going to do
it and it's because i don't want to have
my heart broken yet again i just don't
want to do that but if i sort of remove
that from the equation and just sort of
think with my head only here
i gotta be honest i do think it makes a
lot of sense for hogwarts legacy to be
at this event we're coming up on the end
of the year they've already announced
all the stuff they're going to be really
pushing this holiday season now will we
see some things that are coming out this
year absolutely they're going to be
focusing on third party titles that are
coming out this year but nowhere in this
announcement does it say titles that are
only releasing this year and here's the
thing that really gives me hope guys
because hogwarts legacy we already know
that it was slated to release this year
and was delayed we've been talking all
year is it going to be an early 2022 is
it going to be mid 2022 is it going to
be late 2022 and we've went this whole
entire year without hearing any updates
whatsoever so if there was any shot at
all that we're going to see even sort of
a first half of 2022 release and i'm
talking like january to maybe all the
way through june july that range then
this would be the time for it this would
be the moment now you can't forget about
the game awards that's true it's still
out there it's happening in december so
it could definitely appear there as well
but if we are right that sony has the
marketing for hogwarts legacy which i
think it's pretty clear that they do
then this event right here makes the
most sense i mean to be honest hogwarts
legacy could be here and then again at
the game awards if they really wanted to
start pushing it out but for me i think
it all comes down to just how far along
is it is it gonna release in the first
half of 2022 or is it gonna be a holiday
game if it's gonna be a holiday 2022
game then we're probably not going to
see it here and if we do see it there
then maybe just maybe we'll actually get
a release date now as always i have to
be completely honest with you guys i
love hype i absolutely love building
hype i love being a part of the hype
train when things are really exciting i
think that stuff is awesome around games
but i also think you have to be on the
opposite side of that as well and i have
to be upfront and honest with you guys
when i don't think something will happen
and if i'm putting a number on this i
would probably say the odds of hogwarts
legacy being here are pretty low maybe
around 15 if i'm again that's just me
completely just a guess because i do
think it could be here i think it makes
sense if sony has the marketing rights
to show it here but really the only way
i could see it happening here if it's an
early 2022 release and thus far
everything we've seen doesn't really
indicate that it is now i'd love to be
wrong in fact i hope i am wrong i hope
on wednesday night there's a video going
up of me live reacting to a new trailer
or something like that because
you already know i will have the news up
on it as quickly as i possibly can now
to be completely fair i was all in on
hogwarts legacy being at the last
playstation event and was completely
wrong obviously on that so maybe i'll be
wrong on this one as well and it will
actually show up and i gotta be honest
part of it is probably me just trying to
temper my own expectations so i don't
get let down again because it's already
happened so many times
but maybe maybe guys this is the time by
the way i also want to mention the hat
that i always wear here you guys can
actually purchase one of your own
because we have officially launched a
retro rack into our store and thanks to
you for helping me hit 10 000
subscribers that is actually integrated
directly into youtube so you can see all
the stuff that's on the store right
below this video i think we got some
pretty cool shirts and of course i love
the hat so if you guys check that out
let me know what you like the best as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon